there are a whole bunch of experiments
going on at cern most famously the large
hadron collider is doing its thing but
one of the other experiments going on is
that they're actually um trying to
produce anti-hydrogen
you know we live in a universe made of
matter but
a wonderful
british physicist called dirac
demonstrated that there could be another
class of particles which is called
anti-particles so every particle has its
anti-particle so for every proton
there's an antiproton for every electron
there's a positron
and so just as these elementary
particles exist in principle you can
start putting them together to make
composite things so hydrogen for example
consists of a proton and an electron now
if you took an antiproton the
anti-particle of a proton and a positron
the anti-particle electron and put them
together you could make anti-hydrogen
back in the
1990s early 1990s it was demonstrated
it's possible they managed to combine
the positron and an anti-proton together
and they found
anti-hydrogen
but
they couldn't stabilize it because as
soon as a particle and its anti-particle
meet
they annihilate to create energy light
and
we're surrounded by matter so if you
create a little
an atom of anti-hydrogen
generally it was going to very quickly
and so it would just hit the wall of the
container which it was in hit the matter
and immediately annihilate so they they
they demonstrated they could get it but
they couldn't keep it for any length of
time and so the new development if
they've actually found a way not only
are making anti-hydrogen but actually
trapping it with a strong magnet you can
actually create a magnet which holds
these particles they have trapped 38 i
think it is atoms or anti-atoms if you
like atoms of anti-hydrogen they've
trapped 38 of them for about a sixth of
a second
right so it doesn't sound great but
given that the natural time scale for
these things to
break up on is you know minuscule
seconds you know 10 to the minus 9 10 to
the minus 10 seconds to be able to trap
them and that many of them for a sixth
of a second is a real achievement and so
they're using various combinations of
very strong magnetic fields and electric
fields
because you to stop the particles of
course they mustn't hit any matter
because when mata and nancy mata hit
they annihilate i got i i think it's
probably to do with dan brown and his uh
somewhat uh fanciful stories about the
properties of of antimatter and and cern
that it's got the publicity that it has
in the sense that you know particle
physicists have been making
anti-particles for a very long time it
is a big breakthrough what they are
doing is very interesting the excitement
is you can now begin to do experiments
right you can you because one of the big
questions is is the physics of
antimatter the same as the physics of
matter
does it have the same properties the
slightly strange thing about it is that
the most likely thing they're going to
find is that antihydrogen is very boring
that it's basically indistinguishable
from more than hydrogen but at the
moment you don't know and the whole
point of doing experimental physics is
to try and find the unexpected so for
example we don't even know at this point
whether gravity works the same on
anti-hydrogen and hydrogen at the
energy levels of an anti-hydrogen atom
exactly the same as the energy levels of
a hydrogen atom and so one of the
experiments that they're going to be
trying to do is figure out when you
release these hydrogen atoms whether
they accelerate due to gravity in the
same way the magnetic spins of the two
particles exactly the same and clearly
if they didn't that would tell you
something really rather fundamental
about the laws of physics it's expected
that almost certainly they will
tediously accelerate in exactly the same
way
but if you find the unexpected that's
where the really exciting science lies
antimatter is used and
who knows the applications i'm you know
i doubt dirac when he first
came up with this idea of the
antiparticle realized that it would be
saving lives
right it's used day in day out in queens
medical center across the road
the pet scanner
is the pet means positron emission
tomography they give you a fluid you
which has got some radioactive substance
in it
that radioactive substance decays very
very rapidly and one of the decay
products is the positron
so the positron and it's so it's
circulating across through your brain
and the positrons emitted of course it's
emitted very slowly it's a it's a very
slow process
so it comes and it comes out very slowly
it immediately hits an electron right
which is somewhere in your brain
and when matter and antimatter hit they
annihilate and so it produces light
and you pick that light up in it through
a detector
you you you're lying in a pet scanner
and and and so by doing it they can map
the brain and they can map regions of
the brain that have
you know they can they can look for
problems in their um growths of cancers
and things in some sense
antimatter is sort of the ultimate
source of energy in in that if you take
a bit of antimatter and a bit of matter
and you combine them together you get
pure energy out you can turn that mass
into pure energy by einstein's famous e
equals m c squared equation and always
one of the issues with that is well
that's fine but how do you store your
antimatter because of course as soon as
it comes into contact with regular
matter it annihilates and so you need
some way of storing it and so one of the
practical aspects of this research kind
of a long way down the line is they've
clearly started to find ways to actually
hold antimatter and reasonable amounts
of antimatter the reason why the energy
you get out of these things is at least
in principle dangerous is because going
back again to einstein's equation e
equals m c squared
c is a big number c squared is a very
big number which means that for a
relatively small amount of mass m you
get a lot of energy e
and so as soon as you start getting up
to sort of macroscopic amounts like
grams of of mass then the energies you
release really start getting quite scary
um but in this case they're creating
collections of you know thousands to
millions of atoms and so on that kind of
scale you're still talking about such a
tiny mass m that the e that you get out
even when you multiply it by this big c
squared is still tiny so you know it's
really still not a major security issue